You've seen it happen, right?
A single dumb comment online
suddenly spirals into this
massive crisis.
We're talking firings, public
shaming, the whole shebang.
Well, today we're going to
unpack a really powerful
argument that connects these
modern Internet pylons to some
of the biggest catastrophes in
world history.
OK, let's get into it.
So the author of our source
material here kicks things off
with this, a pretty surprising
self description.
I mean, this is a guy who's deep
into old stories, ancient
history, theology.
So why on earth has he become
one of today's biggest offenders
of really ugly, modern and often
super offensive speech?
That's the puzzle we're going to
try to solve.
So how does it all start?
It usually kicks off with
something small, something
you've probably scrolled past
100 times.
But the author argues that
there's a new and pretty
dangerous pattern at play now,
one that's turning simple words
into full blown weapons.
What really got this author
thinking was this one little
incident after a major political
event, a clip of a student
making this just shocking, off
the cuff comment goes completely
viral.
You know, it's the kind of thing
that maybe a decade ago would
have just vanished, but not
today.
No way.
And that clip does exactly what
viral clips do now.
It just explodes.
It sets off this immediate
furious reaction.
A digital mob forms, the
student's personal info gets
blasted all over the Internet,
and whatever institution they're
connected to goes into complete
total panic mode.
And the fallout is incredibly
fast and incredibly harsh.
The author points out this whole
cascade of people getting fired,
making these public apologies.
And here's the key take away
right A few thoughtless words
aren't just words anymore.
They're now being treated as
actual events that demand
immediate and severe punishment.
OK, so this brings us to the
core idea of this whole piece.
The author has this central
metaphor he uses to explain
what's going on.
He calls it the ladder of
escalation.
And he argues it's this timeless
pattern that explains everything
from a Twitter mob to, believe
it or not, a World War.
And you can see this modern
ladder playing out all the time.
It starts with one offhand
comment.
That comment becomes a viral
clip.
Then comes the massive public
pile on.
And the final rung?
Well, it's often the complete
destruction of someone's career
and reputation.
It's a clear, predictable, and
frankly, a pretty terrifying
progression.
Now, to show that this isn't
just some new Internet fad, the
author puts our modern ladder
right next to this one from
history.
A single assassination in
Sarajevo, right?
That one act climbed the rungs
of alliances and outrage until
it became World War One.
And the treaty that ended that
war, it was so harsh, it
basically just set the stage for
the next, even bigger war.
The pattern he's saying is the
same small acts, when they're
met with fury instead of
procedure, they escalate and
they get out of control fast.
So if this ladder of escalation
is so dangerous, what's actually
letting it happen?
Well, the author points to this
really crucial difference
between our official legal
system and this new informal
system of judgement that has a
ton of power.
Think of it like this.
There are two systems running at
the same time.
On one side you've got the
official US legal system.
It has all these built in brakes
like the First Amendment that
protects speech.
But on the other side, you have
private power.
We're talking social media
platforms, your boss, online
mobs.
They have 0 constitutional
constraints.
They are, as the author calls
them, efficient enforcers that
can ruin your life over a tweet
in a way the government simply
can't.
All right, this brings us to
what's probably the author's
most challenging idea.
He argues that the solution
isn't to get better and faster
at punishing ugly speech.
In fact, he says, we need to do
the exact opposite.
We need to learn to tolerate it,
because that messy, difficult
process is the essential work of
a free society.
And let's be really clear here.
He's not saying this because he
enjoys hateful content.
He says right here he hates the
viciousness.
His defense is all about
strategy.
He genuinely believes that
tolerating ugly speech is, in
the long runway, less dangerous
to a society than empowering
mobs to go on purge missions.
And this gets to the absolute
core of his definition of what
civilization even is.
It's not about everyone being
polite and nice.
It's the slow, frustrating but
vital art of stopping our first
impulse, our desire to grab an
axe or, you know, a digital
pitchfork, and choosing a
process.
It's dead.
So really, we're faced with the
choice between two kinds of
societies.
You have a town that argues
where the currency is, law and
procedure, even if it's slow and
clunky.
And then you have a town that
shoots where the currency is
violence and getting things
done.
Right now, the author's
basically saying that all these
online cancellations with their
demand for quick, satisfying
justice, it's just the modern
version of a frontier duel.
And that leads us to the final
choice, the ultimate question
the author is posing here.
It's a really stark decision
between 2 completely different
ways of handling our deepest,
most bitter disagreements.
See, when you start relying on
outrage and these quick
solutions, there are major long
term consequences.
Naming and shaming becomes how
you govern.
You stop trying to persuade
people, you just cancel their
livelihoods.
And that doesn't solve anything.
It just creates martyrs.
It builds deep resentment.
And as the 20th century showed
us over and over, that kind of
repression often just breeds an
even more extreme reaction.
The argument here is that this
frontier logic, this impulse to
settle things now with force,
it's universal and never really
went away.
We may have put away the dueling
pistols, but the core logic is
exactly the same today.
Our weapons are just different
doxing algorithms and complete
professional annihilation.
So what's the solution?
Well, he calls it an ugly,
simple answer.
Protect the public square, even
when it's messy and filled with
things you hate.
Handle disputes through slow,
deliberate procedures, not
quick, satisfying purges.
We have to train ourselves to
resist that addictive rush of
performative anger.
And most of all, we have to
remember the lessons of history.
And that leaves us with this
final, really provocative
question.
The author's entire argument
kind of boils down to this.
If we as a society formally
decide that words are a form of
violence, what does that make a
legitimate response to that
violence?
The historical answer to that
question is not pretty, and
we'll end with this haunting
warning that ladder of
escalation it's easy to climb
up, but it's almost impossible
to climb back down.
The author's whole plea is for
us to choose the difficult,
frustrating work of argument
over the satisfying warm glow of
the torches, because history
teaches us that once we choose
fire, the path back to
civilization can be lost for a
very, very long time.